أطلقت روسيا مقطع فيديو
لاختبار الصاروخ الباليستي العابر للقارات
لتحديث سلاح استراتيجي رئيسي تمامًا
بينما تمضي قدمًا في هجومها الجديد
في منطقة دونباس بأوكرانيا
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
متفاخرًا بأن الإطلاق كان حدثًا بالغ الأهمية ،
فهذا السلاح الفريد حقًا سيعزز
الإمكانات القتالية  تضمن قواتنا المسلحة
بشكل موثوق أمن روسيا من
التهديدات
الخارجية وتوفر مادة للتفكير لأولئك
الذين يحاولون في خضم الخطاب العدواني المسعور
تهديد بلادنا ،
تم الكشف عن صاروخ rs-28 sarmat الذي يُطلق عليه أحيانًا اسم الشيطان 2 في عام 2016
.  لتحل محل نموذج الحقبة السوفيتية ،
تدعي روسيا أنها تستطيع حمل
رؤوس حربية نووية متعددة ولديها
مدى يزيد عن 6800 ميل مما يجعلها
قادرة على ضرب الولايات المتحدة ،
وتقول روسيا إن الصاروخ أطلق
بعد ظهر الأربعاء من شمال روسيا وهو
يسافر عبر البلاد لإجراء اختبار.
موقع في أقصى
الشرق يقول البنتاغون أن الاختبار لم يكن
مفاجأة  لقد قدموا إشعارًا مسبقًا
بهذا الإطلاق بموجب التزامات معاهدة البدء الجديدة
التي خططت
لاختبار هذا الصاروخ ، وقالت وزارة الدفاع
اليوم إننا لا نعتبر الاختبار
تهديدًا للولايات المتحدة أو
حلفائها ، لكن مسؤولًا دفاعيًا كبيرًا في الولايات المتحدة
قال:  لم يكن الإطلاق شيئًا
يمكن أن تقوم به
قوة نووية مسؤولة في البيئة المتوترة الحالية
حيث يبدو أن حرب بوتين في أوكرانيا التي تجر على
روسيا عازمة على
المضي قدمًا في أسلحتها المتقدمة ،
وألغت الولايات المتحدة اختبار icbm المجدول في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر.
في نقطة هشة للغاية ،
أردت التأكد من أننا نقوم
بأمور حكيمة وندير التصعيد